[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god did you see that sites that
watered amazing twin tips and punished
there oh my god the series of wobble
just because of their you'll stay oh my
god oh thank you
you know that was a good move more
freely I would say oh yeah he'll be able
to be able to kind of against get around
the pandas oh man look at heads-up wrong
- obviously he's gonna be testing them
throughout this matchup most certainly
and he's still in this
oh he stepped right out of rain pink
stuff and now he's got the wall pressure
and another clutch block on the hell
shop and cabbage nice work
although my god just went there it's
gonna be sick so dangerous at this point
okay the local aid the second hit off I
see was able to tackle in here job you
think that stand big launch way to get
the wall here cheese your face from the
cusp of resetting the bracket here and
each start pretty good right now
[Music]
[Music]
you know we're to get caught oh my god
counter it all up don't cut off still in
a good spot Oh buddy Oh
oh my gosh oh wow crazy okay it'd be
cool oh my god she calms me find it let
it loose there gets the bear uppercut
yes big bull damage here oh there's the
dreaded animal stance so big payoff this
could be the turning point you know he's
fighting back he has the wall position
he might even get this round in that
canoe
oh wow wow it's a nice punish I didn't
know you got that much damn how's it on
an empty - nice block party - Wow jab
wanna players here oh my god
he's about to win right this second
[Music]
[Music]
anyone's game although that's gonna be
here it's not anyone's game it's Ranchos
game and he
just me Wow okay Oh Fifi footage yeah
okay out of the air
yeah but it's not gonna be a lot of
damage oh my god he tried to respond to
the big launch of his own the raht to
interrupt counter force that beat
guaranteed on the counter good javelin
lows much better than other careful it's
the survival instance menu cover name of
the game here halogen good for sinks Oh
punished oh really are you gonna tie it
up like this
wow the - Sean's new hips again Oh
[Music]
Yoshio I like the oh my god mine's
lighted so many hot chicks that way and
look overall play style it's soul
playing its ain't heavy
right now doesn't take any big risk
everything is chopped in the first round
just block on it
you're not breaking the truck
one on the way in you two get up
Oh circus bear throw and the fall of
afterwards wasted little time so on the
way down buddy good luck she does
[Music]
Oh
50 seconds Oh heaven
be careful one Morrigan in here jus
dad's oh this is huge
yes he's gonna get the wake up
ain't gonna clutch it out and that's
gonna be
[Music]